here is the reality when it comes to
figuring out where to start the truthful
answer is guess and get going the reason
people say just throw them into the deep
end is because let me tell you you start
trying things real fast when you're
sinking to the bottom of the pool hey
does splashing my arms around like this
work does kicking my legs like this work
just grabbing at the person next to me
and like trying to climb up them does
that work that's you running a bunch of
experiments which you never would have
done sitting on the bank thinking about
it you will not be able to think your
way to success that doesn't mean that
you shouldn't think it just means when
you think and then go either a lot of
time has passed so i would say if you've
thought for more than 72 hours about it
thinking is no longer going to help that
window though very beneficial sleep on
it a couple nights really think through
it do some research but now post 72
hours it's time to take action now that
doesn't mean that we're not going to
think about it anymore we're not going
to research we are a whole lot but that
research magnifies when it's paired with
action so now reading an article
listening to a podcast is paired with
flailing around like an idiot in the
deep end going oh my god now i see what
they were trying to explain in that book
that article that video whatever but
you're never going to be able to make
those connections if you're not actually
in it so you're not going to think your
way to success you are definitely going
to get in there and do your way to
success need motivation watch a top 10
with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best tom bill you and my take on
his top 10 rules of success enjoy
that's a critical thing there's no
magical first step you're so worried
about the first step because you think
that there's some like magical
auspicious first step that's like and i
see this now with um
nft artists where it's like oh man but
my genesis piece means everything and so
they don't create anything because they
are so worried about what their first
piece is
that noise
do something create get out there try
longevity
longevity
that's the game
and if you would
allow me
on the side
there was a class i forget where this is
so interesting bear with me
where an art teacher said
you have two options before you
your final grade can either be based on
a single piece and that's all you have
to create this entire time or
i can grade you based on the pounds of
art that you output literally the pounds
the weight the number of
items that you create i think this was a
sculpture class
so you've got people that are like hey
amazing i'll take all my time i'll do
one thing it's going to be amazing and
she said without question like 95 of the
time the best grades went to the people
that did art by the pound why
because they tried and failed and tried
and failed and they weren't precious
about it and they just got in there and
they got messy and they pushed their
skills forward they got those samples
they learned they researched they tried
they had a whole bunch of stuff that was
garbage but man a few times in there
they really hit on something and they
really learned and they really push
themselves forward
live life by the pound rule number two
use failure to learn here is how to
conceptualize failure and the
disappointment that goes along with it
once you understand
that what the human animal is designed
to do is learn then
you have to ask yourself if what has
made the human animal the most apex of
apex predators the world has ever seen
the most capable of completely changing
its environment
what is it that allows them to learn
fast
and the answer is failure now the reason
that failure is truly useful and i'm not
just saying that to make you or myself
feel better in fact i wish that it
wasn't the way to learn the fastest but
the reality is the reason that it works
so well
is that when you fail you trigger areas
of the brain that are focused on
memory
and focus so you've got the memory side
so you're going to remember this you've
got the pain this does not feel good i
do not want to go through this again so
you've got that which heightens your
emotions which makes you more likely to
remember this thing moving forward and
then it also narrows your attention so
you're really looking at
why did this go wrong and when you have
this sense of i never want to repeat
this and you're looking very closely at
why did this go wrong
now all of a sudden
failures because of what it does to your
brain and quite frankly because you're
in the mix you're trying things and we
learn better from doing than from
reading about it or hearing about it
so failures suddenly become the most
information-rich data stream on planet
earth heightens your likelihood of
remembering and it focuses you in on
exactly what's the problem so now
even though failing sucks part of what
makes it valuable is that it sucks in
fact it may suck in order to make it
let that sink in that nature went huh
when this happens in order for this to
be useful for this animal for this
evolutionary creature i need to make
sure
that it becomes advantageous so that as
they make mistakes assuming that they
don't get eaten by a lion i want to make
sure that they don't put themselves in
that position again and so we have to
learn from
some method and the method that gets us
moving taking action trying things
feeling the pain focusing that's going
to be the thing that we're going to get
the most takeaways from so now
as you reframe what failure is
failure
is not
proof that you're a loser
failure is the process
by which you become better
okay failure is not the process that
reveals that you're a loser failure is a
process by which you become better that
is the name of failure so now when you
fail why would you beat yourself up over
it it's the nature of progress itself
there is no way to get better without
failing it's the fastest way it is the
most effective way it is necessary you
have to do it and by the way for you to
have failed at something you showed the
courage to try it
so instead of wasting time beating
yourself up over the fact that something
went wrong we're going to say
that's the nature of progress we have to
try something it's not going to work as
well as we want it to or i may fall flat
on my face i may outright embarrass
myself and if i let that break me i will
fail to learn the lesson
but if i do what nature is compelling me
to do
and i focus
on what went wrong why did this happen
because i never want to go through this
again
you stack enough of those what went
wrong i never want to go through this
again enough of those together
and you actually get good
and translating potential into skill set
is the name of the game and you will
never do that more efficiently than you
will through failure and mistakes so
allowing yourself to wallow in
disappointment
doesn't make any sense it's the learning
process this is what you have to do in
order to get good so there's no reason
to spend a lot of time being
disappointed you brush yourself off you
pick yourself up you dust yourself off
and you get going
that's it that is the physics of
progress rule number three develop close
loving relationships healthy
relationships are a critical part of the
human experience
if you truly want to live a joyful life
you need to make sure that you have
close
loving relationships
if you don't currently have close loving
relationships
do not pass go
do not collect 200
immediately address that in your life
if you need to start somewhere and you
have no idea where to start man go to a
soup kitchen do whatever but get out
with other people start connecting to
people do something some kind of way
join join a facebook group join a club
virtual or in person whatever weird
interest you have i promise there are
other people out there that have that
same interest this was so 10 years ago
maybe more 15 years ago when i learned
about furries which i still am surprised
is the thing but it is a thing and
the fact that even pre-internet there
were entire groups of people that would
meet up and this is their thing
i thought okay if there's people that
are into that no shade man if that's
your thing that's your thing but if
there is a convention's worth of people
that are into that
then
there is a group of people for every
interest no matter how
niche
so find your people connect
that is hugely important and then don't
look for other people to carry you but
having people in your life that support
you that and this is the easiest way to
explain this from my wife i say
i'm not looking for sympathy
okay i don't want you to feel bad for me
empathy that would be amazing i want you
to understand what i'm going through
now here's how it plays out
i said to her in the beginning
if ever i'm knocked to my knees
i don't want you to get on your knees
with me put an arm around me cry with me
and tell me everything is going to be
okay it's not what i'm looking for and
even worse i don't want to do all that
and then tell me yeah all of this sucks
and it's in life you know life's a
sandwich and every day is another bite
people used to say that all the time
when i was a kid
that was like the tacoma motto drove me
crazy
what i want
my beloved wife
when i'm knocked to my knees which will
happen
i'm going to extend a hand
i want you to show that you understand
what i'm going through but i want you to
pull me back up
help brush me off
and remind me of what i'm capable of
so that i can
soothe myself
refocus
remember that i'm the learner
and
get me pointed back in the right
direction
that to me is the difference between
empathy and sympathy
don't cry for me
help me get back in the fight
so surround yourself with people that
are like that
don't look for them to carry you
having people that remind you of what
you're capable of having people remind
you of what you're capable of becoming
that's rad that's dope
surround me with people like that and
i'm about it
but i don't just want somebody to
cry with me
it's not going to take me where i want
to go rule number four set priorities i
will tell you that my to-do list is
always in order of importance and i
think that there is an optimal order to
do things in so important things 100
using the lead domino strategy so what's
the biggest bang for my buck what could
i spend the next 15 minutes on that
would have the biggest impact
in leading me towards my goals okay
that's how i always think about my
official to-do list now when i think
about a morning routine and what order
i'm gonna do things in
then it has to do with what's going on
in my life at that point what's the most
important thing to me in that moment and
then ordering things accordingly so
there have been times in my life where
the first thing i do is meditate
there have been times in my life where
the first thing i do is go to the gym
and so those are really the big two
things that i um oscillate between but
there are also times where i will
immediately go to work so any one of
those three things may be the first
thing that i'm doing in my morning
routine depending on what's going on in
my life so how do i decide between those
so when i'm really focused on getting my
physique in order i'm focused on
the gym as being the
the thing that i want to make sure that
no matter what else happens during the
day i get that done then i do that first
and that really is what slot number one
is for in any morning routine is what is
the most important thing that you know
no matter what else falls by the wayside
during this day if it gets crazy things
will crop up that i know that i'm going
to get that thing and so right now i'm
going to the gym first there was a long
stretch of time there where i wasn't as
focused on the gym and so it was like
well i'll work out later let me do a
little bit of work first and then i'll
go to the gym and i found what was
happening was instead of working out
five days a week or six days a week i
was working three days a week or
sometimes two days a week because so
much would pop up during the day that i
wasn't getting to it now that made sense
and i didn't change for a long time
because there was so many key
initiatives at impact theory that i was
trying to get to that that was truly
more important to me but then i hit a
threshold event where i was like nah now
i really want to get back in and really
really focus on the gym and
ironically it was because my lower back
started to hurt from under utilization
just a quick shout out to anybody
suffering from lower back pain can
basically tell you what it is poor diet
high inflammation and not deadlifting
enough now that doesn't mean high weight
deadlifts in fact i used to do that now
i just do low rate low weight high rep
but i find that my back hurts when i
don't work it out so again everything's
individual try it out for yourself but
that's important so that's how i judge
what to do first
my typical modus operandi would be that
lifting is the first thing i do
then i would meditate and the meditation
i use what i call thinkitation to get
into then the work so working out
meditating work is typically my path
again
mileage may vary try your own but if
you're not sure what to do you can try
that one it's pretty damn effective for
waking up the brain
then practicing lowering your
heart rate your breathing rate by going
straight into the meditation and then
when your brain has all that clarity
that comes from working out
then you can
leverage that as you
meditate to get the ideas you're going
to need to actually be effective at work
that's why i do it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five believe
once you believe something is possible
once you taste that
thing that other thing like tony hawk
when he was trying to do the 900 he was
like
honestly i didn't know if it could be
done
and so once he landed it then everybody
started doing it and it just became dave
roger like yeah yeah of course if you
can't do the 900 you can't even compete
but it had stood for so long until you
could see oh it can be done
so the mdma thing is it puts you in such
an altered brain state that you realize
you can love yourself again and when you
feel that just intense acceptance and
you're looking at the trauma you're
looking at the trauma do this with
somebody who knows what the [ __ ] they're
doing not saying go to vegas and get
ecstasy
medical treatment mdma find a study
they're out there
but being able to taste that other
thing the other state of loving and
accepting yourself totally
even though the neurochemistry is going
to radically change as you come out of
that you've now tasted it you've run the
four minute mile you know it is possible
you've experienced it you lived it you
were there it's not somebody telling you
about that it is actual to you you know
it's possible and that's the thing about
success that's what i want you guys to
taste i want you to know that this has
been broken by somebody just as dumb as
you
i'm not joking you look at me as like an
after photo i look at me as a before
photo like if you show me this is one of
our first offices
but if you show me
and i don't know if you already rolled
them baby but um show the the photos of
me as a kid
so
genius right
obviously you can tell that kid's right
he's going places
i used to wear that all the time
and yep there's another one this was a
this is a hat i was particularly fond of
so i did not take myself very seriously
so when i always tell the story that
uh
my own mother
who was my biggest cheerleader
quietly assumed that i was going to fail
when i left for college
there she is what's up moms
so
she had reason to believe
that i was going to fail i didn't take
myself seriously i didn't take anything
seriously i cheated all the way through
high school
and
it wasn't until
shame quite frankly
started dragging me out of bed i was
engaged to the lovely and beautiful mrs
elizabeth bill you
and yeah
and
she would come home
this is we were living at her mom's
house by the way
and that's not sexy
living at her mom's house
she was working i wasn't and my only job
was to make her a sandwich when she came
home for lunch because she would come
home for lunch and i would lay in bed
saying i'm gonna get up in five minutes
five minutes i'm gonna get up in five
minutes
and i would lay in bed for three four
sometimes five hours in the morning and
the only thing that got me up was
knowing if i didn't get up right then i
wasn't gonna have her sandwich ready
when she came and that was like a shame
too deep to bear
and so i would scramble down my hair a
mess in just sweatpants the same
sweatpants that i wore every day which
she
did not find very sexy
and i would make her sandwich and be
kind of mad if she seemed a little off
that you know i had i made the sandwich
yeah you know if you could do your hair
maybe that would be nice i was just like
jesus ask ask ask
and
finally i realized
i told her i was going to make her rich
and when i proposed to
when i went to her dad to ask for his
blessing to propose to her he told me no
he wasn't going to give me his blessing
and he asked me a super powerful
question and he said
how are you going to take care of my
daughter
i was broke i didn't have a job
and i said sir look i know uc is
a broke kid who's undereducated
from tacoma washington
and
what you don't see
is that i'm the most ambitious person
you've ever met
and i thought he would be moved
and i thought he would be like
you know what kid good on you
go marry my daughter
and he didn't he was like look you can
have sex with her but for the love of
god
do not marry my daughter
and i'm not joking
he didn't use those words in his defense
but he made it abundantly clear i'm not
old-fashioned tom i'm not old-fashioned
and
they have a greek phrase
sigasiga which means slowly slowly so
that became like the mantra for the
whole family because everybody knew that
andreas had this whole thing where he
wanted me to take it slowly and i was
going far too fast for him and i said
look sorry i respect what you're saying
but i am going to propose to your
daughter
and there i am
she said yes i gave her the whole speech
i'm going to make you rich this is going
to be amazing i've got all this ambition
i'm going to make it happen
and as i'm laying in bed i have a
pivotal
realization which is that there is a
massive chasm between ambition and drive
and i had the ambition and i did not
have the drive to see it through but i
was so ashamed of myself
that that shame actually propelled me
forward because i now had essentially
people watching i had a father-in-law i
wanted to know what i was going to make
myself i had my fiancee who wanted to
know like if i was really going to be
the man that i promised her i was going
to be
and so that got me moving and that got
me headed in the right direction and
that got me into
all the things that you see now but it
was this incredibly long journey of
being disappointed in myself and having
shame and not knowing what i was doing
and being in over my head and spending
so much time in over my head that i end
up developing crushing anxiety because
i'm failing so much and i'm failing so
often but i have not yet divorced myself
from the outcome so because i'm so tied
to the outcome every hit is a hit to who
i am and so i begin turning inward and
i'm thinking less of myself even though
i'm moving up and moving forward i just
spent so much time smack bang on my face
doing something stupid saying something
stupid actually something up and costing
a lot of money over and over and over
and so because i thought that meant
i was bad i was unworthy i was never
going to be able to achieve something it
was sending me into this death spiral
and it wasn't until i really started
having to learn about the brain to get
out from underneath the anxiety that i
began to put a lot of the pieces in
place the rules the beliefs and
everything that ended up allowing me to
catapult forward
and that is
what for lisa and i impact theory is all
about it's just getting people to
realize
you're an average human
being an average human is enough you can
change far more than you think but it's
going to be really
really
hard rule number six change your
self-talk you become
what you repeat
let me repeat that you become what you
repeat now if you become what you repeat
and the thing that you repeat in your
own head is what a loser you are that
things never go your way that the world
is against you that you're hard done by
that you're just not talented like other
people that things weren't meant for you
if that's what you're repeating in your
head that is what is going to become
your reality because
if you predict it right nothing ever
works out for me i'm a loser i always
screw things up okay your brain is a
predictive machine we talked about that
before so your brain is predicting
you're telling yourself on a loop that
this never works out for me i always
screw things up i'm too stupid whatever
your brain then is going to expect to
see that and then basically no matter
what happens your brain is going to find
a way to conform that
to the narrative that you tell yourself
okay and we've all seen people do this
where we're there in a room with them
and we see things well things are like
really working out for them this is
going great and then when they retell
the story they only focus on the
negative parts and it's like whoa were
we in the same room because what i saw
was 80 good sure 20 bad but it was 80
good
and all that person repeats is the 20
that was bad
and because that's their habit that was
all they saw when they looked at that
event and so
really understanding the necessity
of grabbing a hold of that process of
recognizing whatever you allow yourself
to repeat is going to be the thing that
you see it is going to become the
bedrock of your life so if you're
repeating i'm a learner i can figure
this out there's nothing that you can
put on me that on a long enough timeline
i can't figure out these are the things
i tell myself by the way so if you're
ever wondering what it's like to be
inside my head it starts with a negative
thought i refuse to allow myself to
repeat that i do what's called a pattern
interrupt so as soon as i say oh man i'm
too dumb i'm never going to figure this
out i pattern interrupt no
you're the learner do not allow yourself
to repeat that you're dumb and that you
can't figure this out you're the learner
anything that anybody brings you you can
figure out going back to the previous
question i say it with enthusiasm i'm
telling other people i get myself hyped
up i smile i get energetic now my brain
goes whoa the body's like getting really
amped up about this the amplitude of
reaction
will get justified by my brain
and now because i'm repeating it that i
can learn anything on a long enough
timeline i can be anyone at anything
human potential is nearly limitless the
average person is the ultimate
adaptation machine therefore i am the
ultimate adaptation machine i can get
good at anything with disciplined
practice and i'm saying that
i'm saying it in this heightened
emotional way
now all of a sudden my brain is
justifying that whoa we really must be a
learner and this really must be a good
thing because we're saying it with all
this excitement and so now
by repeating that by doing that on a
loop by having that running
40 50 times a day
seven days a week 365 days a year i now
get
an innate emotional response to
challenge that's positive
and that puts me in this positive loop
of where i don't encounter a challenge
and want to stop or want to back off or
feel badly about myself or think about
all the times where i screwed it up i
encounter that challenge
i've repeated so many times that i can
figure this out and i've celebrated my
wins so obsessively and when i do
something and 20 goes wrong and 80 goes
right i'm spending all my time with the
things that went right i learned from
the things that went wrong but i'm
repeating about the things that were
wrong that i can figure this out i can
learn it i can get better
and then on the eighty percent i'm
celebrating it to really lock it in
and so that repetition is exactly how
you make it stick rule number seven
don't lose your excitement you have a
sufficient why
you have a sufficient level of
excitement
now all of a sudden the behavior of
getting up and doing that thing takes
care of itself so one of the most
important things you can do in your life
is to realize that it's critically
important to be excited about the things
you're trying to wrap these routines
around i see so many people
fighting this ridiculously uphill battle
to do a really hard thing
that they don't care about
i have a really hard time doing things
that i don't care about
so i'm always focusing first on getting
myself to the point where i care
now that may mean that you have to
change your life
if you hate your job hate the things
that you're doing with your time step
one is to start doing things that
actually give you more energy than they
take that are exciting to you that
you're amped about that seem worth
pursuing that you look out into your
future three to five years you know
where you want to be and you're taking
meaningful steps to get there having a
dream that is exciting and honorable
and you know that if i do this thing
today
and tomorrow and the day after and i can
make it a habit
and this becomes my routine
now i'm really making meaningful strides
towards my goal all of a sudden when you
don't feel like doing it you just remind
yourself
what you're chasing
you remind yourself what that goal is
and most importantly
you remind yourself why
you're pursuing that goal
it's a great nietzsche quote
a person
with a strong enough why
can survive almost any how
when you know why you're doing something
because it is so thrilling to you the
thought of having that thing is so rad
the process of getting it you've
invested in and you're even enjoying
that process
that's when
it's easy to get that new routine
because you have to let the old routine
atrophy
but the only way to atrophy it is to
replace it with something else just not
doing anything
isn't necessarily going to atrophy those
sort of old habits those old desires
you've got to give something new that
you can lean into that you can be
excited about that you can pour yourself
into that you can fantasize about i'm
going to have that future that's going
to be mine and i'm doing xyz thing and
it's actually moving me towards my goals
when you have that when you have that
sense of progress and you know yo if i
keep doing this i'm pouring myself into
this look i am getting better and if you
take the rate at which i'm improving and
stretch it out over three or five years
or if you're willing 10 years it is
crazy it is absolutely utterly
life-changing when you're pouring
yourself into getting better at
something it is life-changing what you
can do in three five 10 years
so now when you're thinking about it
you're talking to yourself about it
you're talking to other people about it
all you have to do is change your
routine and you get that thing
that's very easy and then when you get
that feed loop of actually progressing
it becomes really easy to cement it
but you need excitement rule number
eight stop overthinking thinking is
super important and overthinking is a
catastrophic waste of time
now i have rules in my life
and this is all a part of how i get
control of my subconscious mind how i
get control of the things that i repeat
how i'm making sure that i'm making the
most of my time
and
what i am obsessed with
is how just how the human mind works so
not judging it not saying oh i wish it
would be different though there are many
things that i do wish would be different
i focus entirely on
recognizing the truth of the way the
human mind works
and the way that the human mind works is
that if you don't take action
you will never
get the full benefit of
the way that
experience
action
has this
magnification effect of the lesson it's
what i call the whiteboard effect
when i was in high school and i was in
math class the teacher would explain
something i would think i had it and i
would go home and i would realize whoa i
actually don't know how this works
the times where they forced me to go up
to the white board even though i didn't
want to do it and i had to actually do
the problem i had to take action i had
to go through it then i realized where
my sense that i understood something met
the reality of i actually don't know
this
and it forced me to work through it that
is life there are things you can try to
think your way through and thinking is
very valuable but it needs to be done in
conjunction with action so you're not
thinking in a vacuum
you're thinking back on the action you
took
so to give you an idea i recently had a
big initiative here at impact theory
which is nfts and
i didn't know anything about it and i
went from hearing the letters nft put
together in that order for the first
time and
48 to 72 hours later we had launched a
major initiative
and and i'm talking multiple millions of
dollars initiative and the team was
panicking a little because
we were moving so quickly but what i
wanted them to understand is i'll never
be able to think my way to understanding
this i can always back out of the
initiative and not end up spending all
the money that we you know had earmarked
for it but to really understand this is
real i have to go down that path
and uh marie forleo has a tremendous
example about this so powerful
about dance class and she was like oh
you know i'm 25. could i ever be a
dancer i don't know and she spent like a
year like hemming and hawing and then
she said she went and took a single
dance class and 20 minutes into the
dance class she knew whether she was
late to the party or not she wanted to
dedicate her life to dance and that 20
minutes in a dance class i had her in
tears and she was just like it was a
transformational moment for her and 20
minutes did what a year could not do and
so when you force yourself to take
action which is the rule that i have in
my life
that i know
action cures all you're never going to
be able to think your way to the right
solution do a little bit of thinking do
enough to have a general direction of
which way you want to go and then take
action i cannot tell you how many
problems that is going to solve for you
in your life take action take action
action cures all
going back to that idea of repetition
right
so that's one of those ideas you should
get very obsessed with go out take
action you will be shocked at how
rapidly
you will get past whatever death loop
you've been in around overthinking now
you're going to take action and then
think take more action and then think
take more action and think so as i go
i'm constantly researching i'm
constantly learning i'm constantly
reflecting on what i do but i'm always
doing
and if you do that it will transform
your life rule number nine wanted badly
enough you are missing desire
you gotta want it
this really is this is the big thing
when people are
procrastinating when they give up when
they seem to lack grit the reality is
you just don't want it badly enough and
when you think of this is one of my
favorite
stories about this and you guys
may have heard this but it's so powerful
i want you to imagine
that somebody grabs you by the back of
the head
and they shove your head under water
imagine how
desperate you would feel to get out from
under that
imagine what you'd be willing to do
in normal day-to-day life if somebody
pissed you off you probably wouldn't
scratch their arms bloody
in normal day-to-day life you might not
claw somebody's eyes out
but if that is trying to drown you
when you start gasping for air there is
nothing that you won't do to get free
nothing
when you want success
as much as a drowning person wants their
next breath
you will find a way
it's the amplitude of desire
that really is
the thing that separates
i'll use me as an example
it is the thing that separates this part
of my life
from the beginning of my
business career
when i wasn't sure i was going to see it
through
i was lazy
i was scared
i was frustrated i was hopeless
and because i didn't know if i was going
to be able to pull it off i was always
ready to give up because it was so
uncomfortable to face the fear because
of my relationship i thought that if i
failed it said something bad about me we
covered earlier that isn't true but that
was certainly what i thought
my brain
for reasons of evolution is lazy and it
prompts lazy choices
so i fell prey to that
my brain was or i was repeating things
in my brain about myself that were
self-defeating
and so it was very hard to
really go after my goals there was a
hesitation
so you've got this dual problem of
of all these things that tell me i
probably shouldn't go after this they're
very scary you're gonna make a fool of
yourself and here oh god this is this is
big
if you think
you're a loser but you don't have proof
there's hope in that
when you try something and you lose
now it's for real
now you really are a loser now you tried
it and you know you suck
at least when you just feared you might
suck
there was no proof
so when i say you've gotta
want it
you've got to want it bad enough to
fight through that period
where
you don't know if you're going to pull
it off
you're afraid that you're going to end
up being a total loser
and the people that go on to do just
extraordinary things with their lives
they're people that want this success so
badly
that they're willing to face
the fact that they might
prove themselves to be a loser which of
course is an illusion and isn't actually
how it plays out but that's they needed
this huge desire
to help them overcome the fear
that they might be as big of a loser as
they think they are and that everyone
else is going to finally see what a
loser they are
so you have to build the desire and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is escape the late
nights i do that because i so
know the value and benefit of sleep i so
love feeling well rested and i so
understand the realities of circadian
rhythms and sleep timing and all of that
stuff that because i'm so obsessed with
the goals that i'm chasing and i see the
reality of how these things impact it
it's very easy for me to put in a rule
says i go to bed by nine simple as and
then stick to it because it gives me an
outcome that i want
this goes back to don't chase things you
don't want
chase things that you want invest in
that and all this stuff gets a lot
easier hate your job find a new one
pursuing dreams your parents think you
should be pursuing find your own dreams
have the guts to stand up to your
parents and say no that's not the life
you want to live
trying to impress your neighbors or your
friends or whatever stop
they don't give a [ __ ] and you shouldn't
either
the whole punch line of life is joy
now once you have that those are the
things you're actually pursuing gets
real easy
to go to bed on time and then make sure
that you're carving yourself out time to
do the things you love so if you're like
yeah but if i go to bed at night i won't
have time to
read play video games hang out with my
spouse whatever
do those things put them on your
calendar make sure that you have time
for them
don't try to sneak in things like that
at night because you think that's what
you're supposed to do or you're supposed
to be you know a good hustler or busting
your ass or whatever look nobody's more
hardcore than me i work 93 hours a week
every week and have four years
i still make time for just outright fun
[ __ ]
even at 93 hours a week there's a lot of
extra hours
so
do things that you love
the reality is
that those who can delay eating the
marshmallow the longest do the best
because you're right delaying
gratification is an absolute superpower
now one of the most extraordinary
experiments was done at stanford
university it's called the marshmallow
experiment there's a whole book written
on this utterly fascinating they
followed the participants in the study
for like 25 years
absolutely incredible they bring these
kids into a room they give them a
marshmallow and they say hey you can eat
the marshmallow now if you want
but
if you wait until i come back
then i'll give you two marshmallows so
it's basically double your money it's
not going to be that long
now what the kid doesn't know is that
the researcher isn't coming back and
they just want to see how long the kid
is going to wait until they eat it they
do eventually come back but they leave
him really to struggle for quite some
time
and
what they found was the kids that could
come up with games whether singing to
themselves not looking at the
marshmallow whatever
the kids that were able to delay the
gratification the longest ended up doing
the best they got the best grades they
got the highest paying jobs they had the
most successful relationships now the
reason that that works is in any one
moment if you're just operating
around optimizing for momentary mind
states brain states neurochemical states
then you're always going to be in
short-term thinking you're always going
to get short-term results if however
you have this
goal that excites you and is honorable
and you're able to push through all the
boring stuff and all of that then what
you get is a set of skills that allow
you to do things other people can't do
and as we established in the last
question if you can do things other
people can't do that is by its very
nature success and you will be rewarded
in a way that other people will not be
rewarded because they can't do the
things you do and as long as the things
you do are valued by society then you
are always going to do very well
but that ultimately is the key you have
to be able to delay gratification now
for me understanding that that was
the nature of things that if i can delay
my momentary wishes for something longer
term then i could get these
very different results that separated me
from other people and because i'm
excited about what i'm pursuing i use
that excitement as my trick to stay
focused when things get boring and i've
said many times that boredom kills more
entrepreneurs than failure so everyone
will tell you that fear of failure is
what stops people and that is a huge
deal but honestly like i think it's the
fact that people don't want the outcome
badly enough to fight through all the
boring
painful stuff that you have to go
through to get to the other side to
ultimately be successful so
make sure that you are hyped up on your
goal if you're not then you're not going
to be willing to go through all the
difficult things let's play a game and
let's call this game
what would tom do
now i want you to ask do you think that
tom is going to stay in a bad job for
long
no
that's the i'll skip to the last page
and
tom has a bad job
skips the last page tom leaves the job
now
tom is going to be very thoughtful
because i completely understand that
this is largely about yo i have to pay
bills hey tom nice for you you don't
have kids and you've already been
successful so that's not really helpful
for me
now i will say that
joy and fulfillment are the punch line
of life not money not success not
adoration so you are losing losing
losing if you're staying in a job that
makes you unhappy i promise if you have
kids and that's the thing that's really
making this difficult you are bringing
that unhappiness home and so
we have a moral obligation to break that
to make sure that we are pursuing things
that are joyful so that we can show our
kids hey this is how it's done
now
you're not stuck at a job there's
something that's making you feel stuck
at the job i'm going to assume for now
that it's money keeping a roof over your
loved one's heads that that to me seems
like the scariest so okay assuming that
it's that remember there are always two
levers lever number one make more money
level number two need less money
okay you can pull on either lever you
want
now if you say up tom i can't need less
money and just we're all we've already
cut it all to the quick you know my kids
just need a certain amount and just is
what it is okay amazing so now we're
gonna make more money awesome how do we
go about doing that first of all let's
identify what we hate about our job
because there might be are there other
roles within that company if it's just
the job but not the company is there
somewhere that we could move in which
case we go ask hey i want this job which
pays more money what would i need to do
what skill set would i need to have what
expertise would i need to demonstrate in
order to get there
and then go do that thing
if it's the company and we just the
company's toxic we can't be there
anymore then i will ask
how many resumes have you sent out in
the last 48 hours if the answer isn't
250 then we've got some work to do
now let's assume that the answer is 250.
then we have to figure out why aren't we
getting a response do we not have a
skill set that's marketable is our
resume terrible are we not going out to
the right places have we not framed
ourselves well
could be any one of those things but we
have to be honest and real and figure
out what we need to do to get out of
this situation but we certainly don't
just accept defeat and go wow this sucks
this is my whole life
nights and weekends is also going to
come to our
help our aid here so nights and weekends
if you know whoa i just don't have the
skill set that i need to go find another
job then we're going to start building
that skill set
maybe the skill set is interviewing
getting good at interviewing and then
we're going to get good at that but we
are going to find a way out of our
situation and we are going to find a way
out of our situation quickly so do not
accept defeat hold yourself accountable
to the truth to what you need to do to
get out of that situation and then get
out
because as you said our time is truly
limited a few things
one
happiness which is incredibly transitory
is probably not the right thing to focus
on the right thing to focus on in my
humble opinion
is
fulfillment and fulfillment has a
formula which is about working really
hard to gain a set of skills
that allow you to achieve a goal that is
both honorable and exciting so you have
to be hyped up about it and it needs to
serve not only yourself but other people
now that's a far more robust resilient
neurochemical state to pursue and i
should have said pursue a goal rather
than attain it because you may never
attain it but the pursuit of it ought to
be the part that is leading you to
fulfillment so you're working really
hard to gain a set of skills that allow
you to serve not only yourself but other
people okay so if we
know that that's what we want to pursue
then the question becomes how do we know
that we're fulfilled how do we know that
we're happy how do we know that we're
sad how do we know that we're anything
and the answer to that question is
really self-awareness and i mean
literally being aware of self so
understanding that emotions spring forth
from the body they are not a top-down
phenomenon the interpretation
of the emotion
is a top-down phenomenon but as lisa
feldman barrett details in her book how
emotions are made it's really a
fascinating
conversation it's probably the right way
to think about it between your body and
your mind and so your body is giving you
these feelings which are in part due to
values that you hold beliefs that you
have historical
experience your genetic composition
and then based on that
context
you feel literally feel a certain way
and then your higher level cognition
tries to paint a story
on top of that emotion explaining why
you feel it but the reality is is being
kicked up by your body and whatever
story you're telling yourself may or may
not be accurate but we believe the story
all the time and this is how people end
up in these negative spirals but you
have to learn to interpret those signals
from your body that's the important part
about assessing where you're at on an
emotional
playing field is you really have to get
good at interpreting those emotions when
i really think about what's the impact i
want to have on the world it's to show
people that it does not matter where you
are today it only matters who you want
to become and the price you're willing
to pay to get there and i it makes me
sad for other people that they think
that i have some natural talent
and
that they then let themselves off the
hook because of that because let me tell
you when i was laying in bed four hours
a day every day in the morning
i didn't feel talented
i'll just tell you that like i felt
like a loser social media didn't exist
there was no way for me to reach out to
people and connect with these thought
leaders you could get tony robbins tapes
and books and stuff and that's what i
did but it's like
man that's pretty far cry from where
things are today and so
i
i felt so hopeless and so lost and just
unsure of how i was gonna make anything
in my life and so for people to be like
oh well easy for you to say you have xyz
talents like
really truly i do not i had zero
instincts as an entrepreneur coming into
it i was a buffoon fell on my face
embarrassed myself it was just stupid
beyond all imagining your brain has
evolved to be a thing
and there is a lot rightly so
of focus in the
popular zeitgeist around mindset about
understanding the mind
and that is critically important but so
few people take the time to really
understand what gives birth to the mind
which is your biology and so
understanding
your
mind
within the context of evolution and the
brain
become critically important and people
that uh don't take the time to
distinguish between the brain and the
mind are doing themselves a disservice i
think much of what they go through is
going to be
it's going to be surprising is what i
was going to say but the reality is what
people end up getting stuck on is they
confuse feeling with thinking
and
the immediacy
of feelings the visceral nature of them
there's something about
embedded in the way that we experience
an emotion is this
just
screaming from our subconscious that
this is real this is true this is
this is like this is it this is the
context everything you need to know dear
mind is contained in this emotion
and
it's really an interesting process that
i
i think warrants a lot more thought on
certainly my part
and probably science's part and for sure
um any of you that are following along
at home uh a big part of what you should
be thinking about
is the nuance of how all of this
comes into being and how
how emotions are
the great trick that they pull is they
they paint themselves to be self-evident
thank you for letting me think in real
time here
this is interesting
emotions feel self-evidently
right i don't even want to say true
because true doesn't capture
what's really going on when i try to
talk about the physics of being human
a big part of that is that
sense
that my reaction
to this moment to this event
does not strike me as a decision
it strikes me as self-evidently
right
because of the things that i feel
and
i'm pretty sure that as we went through
one of the classes i read um a quote by
thomas soul which i'm going to
paraphrase
and it's
the problem isn't that timmy doesn't
know how to read the problem isn't even
that timmy doesn't know how to think the
problem is that timmy doesn't know what
thinking is he confuses it for feeling
and
we feel something
it feels so self-evidently right
that this reaction that we're having is
not an echo of biology and context and
our own life experiences and a bazillion
decisions about what to believe that we
have made it feels self-evidently the
only
logical
way to react to this set of
circumstances and that is what leads
people to spiral because people have
different reactions
they both think they are self-evidently
right and people spiral and so now
re-anchoring you guys back around this
idea of no no you have a goal
the only thing that matters is
will reacting the way that you're
reacting take you towards that goal and
if we can all embrace this idea of
fulfillment that fulfillment is the goal
having a positive emotional state that
is resilient to the ups and downs of
life
because we have self-respect self-worth
we're elevating ourselves improving
ourselves and
elevating improving those around us
if that's our goal and we can all buy
into that
now we have a steering mechanism and
this is the thing that's crazy making
for me in this you know um cultural
upheaval that we're living through right
now
which is
people don't agree on what the goal is
and when you don't agree on what the
goal is now you have what lisa and i
call a collision of values when you have
a collision of values either talk about
the collision of values or shut the [ __ ]
up like legitimately those are your two
options because option one
let's talk about the collision of values
and like what should be the goal
fruitful things can come out of that
arguing about the t as lisa and i called
the biggest argument we ever had was
over a cup of tea now you can imagine
that doesn't make any sense how could
you ever get in a fight that large over
a cup of tea the answer is you can't but
you can get in an argument that big
about a collision of values which then
attacks your sense of self identity
there's this incongruous thing where
your reaction feels self self-evidently
correct
and yet this person is acting
in a crazy way because the way that i
feel
that is self-evidently
correct there's no need to even question
it it is obviously right
now
you get these massive fireworks because
the other person is thinking the exact
same thing
they feel self-evidently correct because
they have all these emotions that are
kicked up by their biology that is
kicked up by millions of years of
evolution
misinterpreted through this
lens that we live in called life
in a modern context completely removed
from the evolutionary soup
that our brains marinated in
our brains
marinated in as they were formed
and now all of a sudden people cannot
allow themselves to conceive
that oh this emotion was a choice
which i have made somewhere through a
string of the gazillion little moments
that led up to right now in this moment
all of those decisions have formed a set
of values
and those values are essentially
invisible to me because i have mistaken
them for truth therefore my values
become water right to the fish fish is
the last one to know what water is it's
just it permeates everything in their
world it just is it's like us in air
right that actually had to be discovered
imagine
the
hundreds of thousands of years like
really think about how long where you've
got human level cognition as we think of
it today
and yet there's no concept of
i'm in this thing
it just
you're here
and values become
that water
you don't even think about them you
don't think that they govern essentially
every aspect of your life
and yet they do
and the failure to recognize that my
values are
not objectively real they are simply
choices that i have made invisibly
based on all these emotions that i've
gotten which were kicked up to me by
evolution
i don't understand them i don't
understand what drives them but they
feel self-evidently true therefore i go
with them therefore however i feel i
confuse with thinking and i think i've
thought through the problem i think i
have articulated what my goal is and how
i'm going to get there but the reality
is i've just been feeling this whole
time
and
chaos ensues i know
that what matters in life
is how you feel about yourself when
you're by yourself
and that how you feel about yourself
when you're by yourself is largely a
function of your identity what you
believe to be true about who you are
and i know that it is critically
important to earn credibility with
yourself and to earn credibility with
yourself when you say you're going to do
something you must do it and if you
don't then you won't have credibility
with yourself you won't be able to
respect yourself and unfortunately you
probably won't have a lot of self-worth
one of the keys to developing self-worth
is to recognize
what you think is worthy
and then to do that
and so doing that thing is going to
become
incredibly important
and that's why i have these rules in my
life that's why i focus on identity now
there's a statement i use to understand
where my identity is which is i'm the
type of person that i'm the type of
person that when i say i'm going to get
out of bed in 10 minutes or less i
actually get out of bed in 10 minutes or
less now that makes me feel good about
myself
i'm the type of person that
believes so much in what he's building
that monday through friday if i'm awake
i'm either working or working out
right so you
build these identity statements into
your life that when you adhere to them
they make you feel good about who you
are they represent something in your
value system that you believe to be true
and worthy
and when you do that and then you adhere
to those things then you're going to
feel way better about yourself and the
desire to capture that feeling about who
you are over and over and over becomes
the very thing that propels you out of
bed and gets you going and moving
towards your dreams so i cannot stress
the importance of that enough if
something is really high value really
important the most important thing you
could be dealing with then you're gonna
do
everything you can do to move that ball
forward now inevitably no matter what it
is there will be times where you will
get to the point where
you need a break or there's nothing more
that you can do whatever
and so you're gonna do everything that
you can do to push that ball forward and
then once you need to move on for
whatever reason
then or you're waiting for something
then you go and focus on the smaller
things but don't be afraid to say this
is my number one priority and so other
things are going to get less attention
so one thing i always tell people at
impact theory is
doing less
is always an option
what's not an option is hating your life
okay so we're not going to do things
that allow us to hate our life so if i
know hey i've got a health issue i have
to go really ham but i also have all
this nicknacky [ __ ] that i have to
deal with
i'm going to take care of my health
first and foremost i'm going to cut out
things that don't have
you know anything to do with that
because they are less important to me
and we went through this with lisa and
that meant that she was doing less at
work um you know if you have to take
paid time off or whatever do it if you
have to take unpaid time off do it if
you have to scale your lifestyle back to
make sure that you can take unpaid time
off do it there are a thousand ways but
when something is truly the most
important thing then you need to address
it as such
now what i find is everybody tries to
have these dueling competing number ones
they think that they're supposed to be
doing all of these things at the same
time
i'm just here to tell you that's not how
it works so you have to put things in
rank order there is no such thing as a
dual number one priority
okay there is number one there is number
two three four five six so on and so
forth okay so line them up do them in
that order and you have to be relentless
about it and you have to accept that not
everything is going to get done as well
as you want to get it done but it should
get done in priority order
i find people have a really hard time
with that that one to me is a bit weird
if your priorities are listed in order
of the things that are important to you
why would you do them in any other way
unless you're lying to yourself about
what's actually important to you
so if what's really important to you is
what your parents think about you well
then you might start making stupid
decisions because you're not being
honest that what you really want is to
please your parents now once you start
being honest
about what your priorities are like for
instance let's say you have a health
issue and you have kids and the reality
is that your kids are your number one
priority and your health is number two
now what do you do
you've got a choice you either have to
de-prioritize your children which is
going to be hard for some people or your
spouse or your job or whatever but be
honest and if you're not prepared to
de-prioritize your kids then you have to
own that and accept the consequences
namely depending on what your health
issue is you may die younger than you
otherwise would because you're not
addressing it
this is where we got to be honest we
have to say what's really going on we've
got to say what our priorities really
are and when we stop [ __ ] ourselves
about what our priorities are then we
can execute in priority order and then
everything in life gets clear and simple
doesn't get easy
but it gets clear and it gets simple
do it to it as my mom would say if you
have a one million dollar business
you'll get want to get it to 10 million
what's the best way to distribute your
time between
marketing training your employees
developing yourself all right everybody
what does it start with
clarity of your goal
so what's your goal
10 million dollars a year that's just
money how are you going to get there why
are we are we just chasing money
yes sell drugs
you might go to jail but damn
on the way up baby
can make some the next best thing
crypto
then flipping nfts but you go broke real
fast doing that but damn if you hit i
made a hundred thousand dollars in 48
hours on a single nft that i bought for
250 dollars not financial advice let me
tell you
but those are really dumb ways
crypto's not dumb but those are like
really sort of roll the dice bet at all
on black ways if all you care about is
money it will send you down a very dark
path that i'm not super helpful at
once you have a goal and there's like a
thing behind you
but even setting all that aside i will
just say you have to be in an industry
where the upside potential is big enough
that you could actually solve a problem
remember this starts with i'm solving a
problem for somebody who knows they need
that problem solved
and then i'm going to go solve it better
than anybody else that's the real answer
but if i could change your life because
this will matter so much
business is a game of attrition most
people give up why do they give up
because hard things suck
so
when you have a hard thing who has read
man's search for meaning by viktor
frankl
i wanna is that really it
scream that out if you've read it
[Applause]
okay this is the
the most important thing i will say to
you literally in this whole talk every
single person in this room if you were
serious about enjoying your life
read man's search for meaning by viktor
frankl it is about a guy who survived
the concentration camps he happened to
be a neuroscientist and what he realized
was you could predict when someone would
die within 72 hours because they would
lose a sense of meaning and purpose
now if you can survive auschwitz on
meaning and purpose alone
let me tell you how important meaning
and purpose is in a business because as
hard as building a business has been
it's no auschwitz
so
trust me when i say meaning and purpose
will get you through when i was building
quest
it was all about saving my mom and my
sister that was what i attached to it
and so when i was there at 2 am on a
friday night with bloody knuckles fixing
a piece of equipment that i did not want
to be fixing
i would think of my mom and my sister i
would not think of 10 million dollars
because nature
has compelled me to think of them in a
way and i get an emotional reward i
won't get from anything else so even if
you're just gonna chase the 10 million
make it about your kids giving them a
better life or something but think about
that other something
we good how do you know when it's time
to refuel and choose self-care instead
of continuing to grind
physiological self-awareness is critical
i hear a lot of talk about people
developing psychological self-awareness
so understanding
what you're good at what you want to do
all of those things incredibly useful
but understanding how to read your body
may be even more important than that so
lisa feldman barrett's book how emotions
are made
detail the way that emotions are far
more of a bottom up phenomenon meaning
they come from your body it isn't you
thinking about something and then
creating the emotion down that does
happen and of course you can spiral
yourself out of control simply by
thinking but usually what begins this
thinking process is a sense of unease
right anxiety is a bodily feeling often
times disconnected from what you're
thinking
so figuring out oh why do i have the
sense being able to process it
consciously we can pull it up into our
conscious mind and think through it with
words and logic but oftentimes it's
starting with that like oh man i don't
feel good about this and i don't know
why so this is the fascinating thing
about drugs is drugs can either
eliminate or change the bodily sensation
which then changes the story that you're
telling yourself about the sensation now
this isn't an advertisement for drugs
it's to get you to understand that it
can be risky to sever
the sense of body from what you're
telling yourself about it so you want
your body to give you this description
of what is going on but then as you take
conscious control of that to develop
that self-awareness around
physiologically what's happening you
need to understand why you're feeling
the way that you feel and so developing
that to get a sense of whether
this is a time to keep pushing through
or whether this is like one of those
moments where you actually really do
need to step back it's the difference
between sore muscles from you know a
nice hard workout and a torn muscle or
damaged joint from uh an injury and the
same thing is true when you're thinking
about how hard to work how hard to push
yourself you need to figure out this
fatigue that i'm feeling this unease
this anxiety this stress is this a
natural part of pushing through the
difficulties of this project or is
something else going on this is now
really starting to cave in on me and
what i need to do now is take a step
back
meditate
journal
hug my significant other pet my dog
cuddle my kids whatever the case may be
go for a run
but doing something that
slows you down
lets you take a deep breath
and the only way to figure that out
is to be able to interpret
the feelings that your body's giving you
into conscious thought okay and getting
good at that loop is very very important
and it takes practice it takes
understanding what the body is
communicating why it's communicating it
what impacts it like what you eat and
drink has a huge impact on what your gut
is telling you and then your brain tries
to make sense of it and it doesn't
always go oh i'm feeling anxious because
in my case i was drinking a zero calorie
monster which much to my dismay because
i absolutely love them
make me feel anxious and so
getting an understanding of that
seeing that pattern was actually quite
transformational because i stopped
drinking them and my anxiety levels
plummeted
by like 70 it's pretty crazy didn't take
me to zero but it made it a phenomenon
that was easily manageable through
meditation
so
this is where you have to develop that
awareness that pattern recognition and
be able to say oh i feel this way
because of xyz thing happening at work
or with my spouse or with food that i'm
consuming so be very thoughtful about
that and that will then help you
determine whether it's we need self-care
or we just need to push through we're
leading people into the unknown we're
leading them into whether it's business
danger or emotional danger and at the
end of the day sometimes people are
going to get hurt they're going to fail
whatever they have to be resilient they
have to learn
but if you're willing to do that if
you're willing to be the human
equivalent of a battle axe and get in
there try things hard things fail
practice get stronger
learn grow
then over time despite the scars
you are more capable
capable
capable you can do things other people
can't do i'm obsessed with that idea i
want to be able to do things other
people cannot do
now when you can do things that other
people cannot do
now you've got a real shot at
whatever it is that you're trying to do
i want to i want my name to echo through
the annals of history no i don't need
other people to want that
but i want that
and i know
for me to actually pull that off which
by the way my identity is not tied up in
that my self-esteem is not tied up in
that i could die completely unknown what
i value myself for is the pursuit but i
sincerely pursue that and to sincerely
pursue that i have to become capable of
things other people are not capable of i
have to be so good that i cannot be
denied that's my obsession i love that i
want that for you guys to both
be willing to play at that level every
day and yet not judge yourself if you're
not there yet that you only judge
yourself by the sincere pursuit of
something that you show up every day
playing to win trying to be the best in
the world at something that you care
about
being unafraid to lead to be out front
to fail people sometimes to own it to
say hey
i failed you
and this is why and this is what i'm
gonna do next time to get a different
result
and you will be shocked
at how people will follow you more
when you just own it
when you tell them what your plan is to
get better and they see you on the front
lines improving
people will fall in line i feel all the
time
but on balance people see the rate at
which i improve
they see that i have a goal and i'm a
servant to that goal
and then i build skills based on what
will take me to that goal
and because i win on balance more than i
lose
people still follow where should a
person start with improving their
self-care if they have low self-esteem
do you think leveraging one
can directly improve the other okay
you've really got two issues here
but they are inextricably linked
you've got biology you've got psychology
the self-care is largely going to be a
question of biology getting the sleep
eating a diet that
at a cellular level is serving us at a
microbiome level is helping us at a
cognition level is helping us right
setting us up for success
meditating making sure that we get that
background stress and anxiety radiation
down to zero
huge in terms of getting you into a calm
and creative space so that you can think
through difficult problems
all of these things are
what you're going to
need to do if you want to do well in
your life now
self-esteem
is a whole nother issue self-esteem has
everything to do with what you think
about yourself when you're by yourself
now you have to earn your way to that
and so the key to earning your way to
that is to figure out what is your
value system
what do you value
what do you think is the way that people
should be spending their time and their
energies and then are you doing things
in accordance with that and then there
are things that are baked in that are
innate so there are these innate drivers
given to us by evolution uh hard work
the desire to contribute to the group
meaning and purpose
deep connection with other people that
we love okay these are you have that
imperative there is nothing that you can
do to shake that imperative and so
understanding how it works and
understanding how you need to meet the
needs of that if you want to be
fulfilled and be joyful is critically
important so as you go about teasing out
whether you have a self-care issue a
biological issue a self-esteem issue
something that is either we're not
addressing the imperatives to contribute
which is sort of the easiest one to go
to
or
we've let the self-care get so out of
whack we're not sleeping we're not doing
all of those things that it's really
beginning to
debilitate us
from doing the things that we need to do
in order to build up our self-esteem now
your self-esteem is really built around
the framework of congruence i said i was
going to do it i'm going to do it so
that when you say you're going to do
something you actually do it and then
whether that's a promise you make to
yourself or to somebody else and then
the
fulfillment formula which is to work
really hard to gain a set of skills that
are unique to you and matter to you or
exciting to you and that they serve not
only yourself but other people
and so if you're doing that working
really hard to get exceptional it's
something that matters that the world
cares about and that you love and then
you contribute in a way that elevates
you and other people
that's the game of fulfillment and so if
you're doing that i think you will find
that that will take care of self-esteem
but if you're not doing that if you're
not finding ways to contribute to the
group if you're not progressing in your
life then you're going to really
struggle with that
so
you do the self-care to make sure that
you can actually build the self-esteem
by contributing in that way
and then those two things work
wonderfully together but you have to
recognize that they really are two
separate issues and they both need to be
addressed what i find is the thing that
people are always if somebody's gonna
compliment me the thing that they're
gonna compliment me on is tom you always
seem so prepared for your interviews
and my thing is like
the only way to win in life
is to be more prepared than everybody
else if you want to win a gold medal in
the olympics you actually have to be
better at that sport than any other
human being on planet earth
that's business
you're going here's another one this
drives me nuts
people will say tom if i because i
always tell people you have to work hard
smart and long hours
and the inevitable question that i get
is
tom
if i work hard and smart
why do i need to work long hours
because you're going against me and i'm
willing to do all three
so now what
there there's no arbiter other than
being better right if your game is to be
stronger you better be able to lift more
weight
if your product solves xyz problem it
better actually solve it and better than
anything else so the presentation is hey
look guys i'm a nervous wreck i hate
giving presentations but the one thing
that i know about my product it will
outperform and i invite you now to put
me in whatever circumstance you need to
and i'm going to show you that it
outperforms this is why trust me if
albert would let me i would stay here on
this stage and answer every single
question i would let people push me and
say no but tom you haven't solved my
problem i will keep going until we solve
your problem now i don't mind doing that
because it's first principles thinking
it applies to everything i know my
product is better so i will just stand
here and do this moment after moment
after moment
when you get as confident in your
product as i am in my ability to solve
business problems
presenting will be very easy when you
were making your transition into being
successful how did you combat the
frustration of not being where you
wanted to be
i'm never where i want to be so i'm not
where i want to be now i'm not where i
wanted to be when um you know people
would have looked at it and said oh my
god this is like the height of success
it was
one i'm very careful to make sure that
i'm only invested in the process but
because i'm trying to get somewhere that
intentionally i'm throwing way beyond
where i'm at i'm always thinking about
what it's going to take to get to that
next level i'm never aware i quote
unquote want to be
but i don't trick myself into tying my
value to achieving it so i'm having fun
i'm enjoying the ride i'm in it for the
process i'm in it for the learning and i
make sure that i'm hand crafting my life
to
optimize for joy and fulfillment
and so knowing that i cannot guarantee
the success i cannot guarantee ever that
anyone is ever going to be successful
but i can
guarantee that you're going to struggle
guarantee
100 nobody avoids it that's it
everybody that ever tries to do anything
and even most of the people that don't
try to do anything are going to struggle
profoundly
with
moving forward
it's just
hard like that
and so if you know that the struggle is
guaranteed then
you can't allow yourself to waste time
to be tormented by the fact that you're
not where you want to be
make sure you're having fun in the
struggle
figuring out how to struggle well that's
the answer
when i was coming up the question i was
told to ask myself was
if you knew you couldn't fail what would
you do
and what i realized is since failure is
the most obvious answer that's probably
not the right question to ask
the right question to ask is what would
i do and love every day
even if i were failing
now failure is never going to be as fun
as winning i know that but
if you can do something that you believe
in enough and that the act of trying to
get good at it is fun in and of itself
now you're on the right path
that's where you want to focus put your
time and energy into making sure
that
you love
the process
don't worry about the outcome worry
about the process getting better and
loving that everything else will take
care of itself first and foremost
we are going to have to figure out
what exactly has happened
so
is it that you don't have a dream or
passion because you haven't taken the
time to
define that because let me be very clear
passion
is not
an archaeological dig
it's an architectural build
so you don't turn inwards look inside
yourself and find this glowing ember of
passion and excitement
that's been sitting there since birth
despite that some people will tell you
that that's how this works but it is not
if steve jobs were born a thousand years
ago he would not have dreamed of making
the iphone what ends up happening is you
decide
there is something that you decide means
enough to you that you're going to
invest in it
and then over time that investment turns
that thing into a
deep and abiding passion as you get
better and you get feedback from the
world that they value this thing that
you're getting better at
but it isn't just
lying dormant within you and this is
like the number one confusion that i
encounter with people is they think that
either they're broken
and other people
were born with a passion and they were
not
or
they just think that
you know if i do enough introspection
i'm gonna find something sitting inside
of me
and finally my life will be amazing
once you realize that in fact what
happens is when you look inside all
you're going to find are these um sparks
of interest and from that spark of
interest
through pursuing it
as
a process of gaining mastery
it will become a passion
when you're able to use that skill set
that you gained in the pursuit of
mastery to serve not only yourself but
other people okay so doing that now
you're in this passion loop of you
worked really hard you gained a set of
skills allows you to serve other people
they give you feedback oh my god thank
you this is so amazing i'm grateful for
what you've done build created given me
whatever the case may be and that feels
good which makes you want to go get
better and that's the passion loop
now as you're doing that
you're able to really be energized by
the things you're doing
but
it doesn't start by looking inward and
finding something it starts by realizing
that you have to fan those flames of
that spark of interest to turn it into
the raging inferno that you want to feel
of that passion but that comes from that
loop
okay so that's the first thing to assess
now if you already have
or had a passion but this job has
somehow beaten it out of you that's a
very different story and so if that's
what's going on we need to figure out
what is it in the structure of that that
is robbing you of that what's going on
exactly that's making this overwhelming
or stressful or not fun is it politics
in the office is it just the work
environment is too fast-paced is it that
you're not being honest with yourself
about you know going back to this idea
50 of you is hardwired 50 of you as
malleable if the hard-wired part is out
of step with the life that you're trying
to lead there can be a lot of
frustration there so having the
self-awareness to understand did you put
yourself in the wrong position are you
trying to be steve jobs when you should
be steve wozniak that's a really
imperative thing to look at
now i find that a lot of times
companies have their own issues whenever
you get a large group of people together
there are going to be weird things that
have to be navigated but at the end of
the day
while you can't control everything that
everybody does you can always control
how you react and so you can reorient
yourself within a company to figure out
one if there's a
path back to finding that joy but that
comes from breaking down what exactly
happened that made you stop feeling the
joy
and two are you able to perform at a
high enough level that you're able to
create the space for you to get back on
track because if you're going to go in
and try to move things around and make
some changes within the company or
within your role or within how things
work you're gonna need to be performing
at a very high level to have the
credibility to make that ask and this is
where it gets difficult nobody wants to
hear this i get it everybody wants to
point fingers and say this is just a
toxic company but in reality if it's
that bad leave
do not waste time start find another job
first i'm not just saying quit
find another job but get out of there
don't act like you're actually in prison
you are not actually in prison and yes i
understand that you have
obligations and you may be a single
parent with kids and huge responsibility
i completely understand and i have the
most empathy for that in the world but i
want you to understand
you are only as trapped as you allow
yourself to be if you have a useful
skill set you will be able to find
another job and now is the time to go
looking for that while you're still
getting paid
now if you don't have skill set that's
marketable
that's where we have to start
and so
building up the skill set
so that we can be marketable somewhere
else that's going to give us the ability
to perform where we are or leave if it's
too toxic but assuming that we're going
to stay
now we need that skill set to perform at
a very high level to create the
credibility to make the ask and go to
your boss or whomever is creating or
maybe not even creating the problem but
who has the ability to help you create
the solution now you go and say i'm
performing at a high level yes yes oh my
god you're amazing okay cool here are
the things that i would need to change
so often people's first instinct is just
peace out and they don't realize that
there are many things that they could
have done
to restructure the role to create more
space for themselves in order to stay
but what people end up letting happen is
they let themselves burn out and then
they want to leave and go somewhere else
not realizing that they will have the
same problem at the next job
and instead of doing the work themselves
solving the internal problem of how we
ended up here whether it's lack of skill
set not setting boundaries whatever the
case may be
but keeping that ownership keeping that
responsibility recognizing that if you
make different choices you get different
outcomes so that you can go ahead and
change things there now again if you
want to leave leave by all means take
your skill set and go elsewhere but make
sure that you're not doing what i was
doing in my early 20s when i was about
to move to new york because i was
unhappy in la and i thought that la was
a problem in reality it was my mindset
once i changed my mindset suddenly i was
amazing
because it wasn't about la
it was about me and i thought ah like
something's got to change and so i just
wanted to go as far away as i could but
it wouldn't have solved the problem i
would have gotten to new york only to
have the same issue again and again and
again
i had to address my mindset and once i
did that then everything changed
so
be very careful be very thoughtful
about
how you approach unwinding
this problem
if you're always blaming other people
you're not going to get where you want
to go because you're not looking for the
things that you can do differently
you're
letting your psychological immune system
take over
make it other people's problems
and then you're not able to
change
and once you realize that your life is
an exact reflection of your choices
now it's not so you feel bad it's so
that you remember if you make different
choices you get different outcomes and
so now you can make these changes or
gain more skills or whatever it is
that's needed to get the life that you
want now no matter where you go you will
feel completely comfortable that you can
shape things to your liking but you have
to know how the game works
you have to know that building skill set
is the key you have to know that
communicating with your boss what's
working what's not working and to have
earned the credibility to make the ask
do all that you'll have no problem
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome do you see
my recent sit down with tom bill you
check the interview right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there people
make bad decisions because they need to
protect their ego and they get put in a
situation where the only way to protect
their ego is to hide or be defensive or
whatever if you invest like that
then you're good and it doesn't matter
pretend i'm on my deathbed